- All right, so it's
11:00 am here in New Haven
in Connecticut.
I'd like to welcome you all to Yale,
to this very special event,
a webinar between two distinguished
alums of the department.
I'm actually sitting right in front
of the Department of Economics,
where we have not been
located for the past year
during the Zoom era, but
it's a beautiful spot
as the Governor knows,
and as Tavneet knows.
It's a beautiful spot,
and I know some of you are
considering coming to Yale,
perhaps as part of our IDE program,
and I hope that you can
experience this spot
for yourselves next year.
So let me just say that
what we're here for today
is to celebrate the long
history of the Yale IDE program,
which really was the precursor,
it preceded the creation of
the Economic Growth Center,
both of which have a very
long and storied history
here in the department,
and I think because of
these two institutions,
the department over the last
50 to 60 years, really 65 years
has grown into one of the world's centers
for development economics.
And not only doing
research, but doing policy,
you're asking the biggest questions
and trying to change the world really
and answering those policy questions.
How do we develop?
So we have a long and storied tradition,
and it's a central part
of the identity of the
economics department.
It actually goes back to,
I guess, Lloyd Reynolds.
I've read a history that Michael Boozer
who's the current director
of the master's program wrote
and so I read some of that
in preparing for this talk,
I learned some things.
So the history goes
back to Lloyd Reynolds,
who was chair of the department before me.
I'm the current chair, by
the way, of the department.
It goes back to the '50s,
and then he brought in
someone named Robert Triffin
who created the International
and Foreign Economic
Administration program,
which Bob Evenson then in the
'60s, renamed to the current
International Development
Economics program.
So we have a long and storied history.
Today, we have two of our
illustrious grads of the programs.
One, of either the Yale economics program
or the IDE program or both.
So we have here Governor Patrick Njoroge.
I hope I'm pronouncing
that roughly correctly,
'cause I read about it on the web,
so thank you very much,
who has graciously decided
to agree to join us today.
He received his PhD from
Yale in 1993 if I'm right
and has worked
in the International
Economic Policy Community
for a long time, the IMF and elsewhere,
and is now the Governor of
the Central Bank of Kenya.
And I should say that
we have a long tradition
of central bankers coming from
the Yale economics program.
Of course, there's Janet Yellen,
who's now the secretary of the treasury
who is got her PhD in '71,
Urjit Patel who won the
Wilbur Cross Medal last year.
A very prestigious medal that we give
to our illustrious grads from
Yale received his PhD in 1990.
I just learned today that the Governor
of the Bank of Thailand
is also a Yale PhD, 1994.
I won't try to pronounce his name today.
I didn't practice that one.
So, and then Tavneet Suri is also here.
She is not only a Yale
PhD, but a graduate.
One of our illustrious graduates
of the master's program
in IDE.
And many of our graduates
have gone on to great things
in policymaking and academia.
And Tavneet is one of the role models,
I think for many people.
She's worked in many aspects
of research and policymaking
as a professor at the
Sloan School of Management,
but also as a very active
member of the J-PAL,
the Poverty Action Lab MIT.
So we're very happy to
welcome her here too.
So with those words, let me just say,
I'm looking forward to
today's discussion on FinTech,
which is a very important area
that Tavneet has worked hard on.
I know, especially, so I
will pass it over to you
and I look forward to our discussion.
- Great, thanks, Tony.
I really appreciate it.
And thanks for the kind words.
Yeah, we do have a storied
history of central bankers,
which is interesting.
Maybe more to come.
So thanks for everyone who's
here, and who's attending.
The way we decided to run this event
is just have a conversation.
Governor Njoroge is a
pleasure to have you here.
(speaks in foreign language),
as we would say. (laughs)
And I'm gonna have a
conversation with the Governor,
and then we'll try and open up to Q&A.
The way the Q&A will work for folks,
please type in your questions
into the Q&A in Zoom
and I'll moderate and
read them out as we go.
And you can upvote the Q&A
in the Q&A function of Zoom.
So please use that if you have questions,
and I think we're off to the races.
Governor, welcome again,
thank you for being here
on behalf of Yale, on behalf of all of us.
It's really nice to start
this series of celebrating
both the Growth Center and
the IDE program at Yale,
sort of kicking off the
celebrations with this event.
And we're really glad you can be here.
So welcome.
- Thank you, Tavneet.
- Yeah, great.
So let me start early days,
and ask you a bit about
kind of your career path,
and how you ended up in
Central Bank Governor in Kenya.
And maybe you can tell us
a bit about that journey
and how you got there.
- Thank you, Tavneet.
And first I'd like to thank, Tony,
and everyone else in my
alma mater for the invite,
and I'm definitely delighted
to be back, though virtually.
And thanks, Tony, for that
background on your Zoom portal.
And really my journey
started way back when,
well, as an economist really,
when I did my undergraduate and master's
in the University of Nairobi,
I was quite interested in economics
more so that I can change the world,
not so much in the sort of modern way,
but maybe changing the lives
of people in particular ways.
So in any event, I did that
and then of course came to Yale
which was a very exciting time.
We can talk a bit more about that.
And after doing my PhD,
I went back to Nairobi
and worked in the government
ministry of finance,
and then eventually decided
that I had seen enough
of the ministry.
And I got a job at the IMF from 1995
where I was for 20 years.
That was very exciting.
I mean, really that is where
I learned to become a real,
I mean, I was nurtured in a sense
and improving my skills et
cetera, 20 years of that.
But I was happy with what I was doing,
and even career wise, et cetera.
And that's when this job came up,
the job of the Central Bank Governor.
I wasn't very interested
in it at the beginning
'cause I had everything
sort of in front of me,
but then I had this nagging problem
which is maybe I could make
a difference at home in Kenya
having worked with all
sorts of other countries.
Maybe I could, maybe I won't,
but I could never really tell.
I could not tell unless I tried.
So that's what I did.
So I applied and here we
are, 5 1/2 years later
as the Governor of the
Central Bank of Kenya.
- Great, thank you.
Yes, we'll talk more
about you being Governor
in a little bit.
But let me ask a little bit about the IMF
and the transition from the IMF
to being Central Bank
Governor to moving back home.
I spent a lot of time at home,
but I haven't quite moved
back home yet like you.
So how was that transition,
and how has it been
over the last few years?
- Yeah, first, I mean I did
enjoy my time at the IMF.
It was great.
I was challenged as an economist,
and really honed my
skills as an economist.
The transition from sort
of classroom paradigms
to sort of actual policy and
discussion with the authorities
in governments, across
geographies, et cetera.
I mean that I think was
very good training ground,
and I learnt a lot and really
got that sort of instinct
of where things are, et cetera.
So that was very exciting.
Of course we have very interesting people
that were interested,
that are still interested
in development economics generally.
but I think policy was
obviously important.
One of the things that I
learned there of course
was a phrase that one of the gov--,
I guess somebody told me,
which is no one cares what you know
until they know how much you care.
And that I think is something
that has stayed with me
all this time and all these many years.
But the transition coming back home,
of course you're coming back home
from let's say an environment
where everything is all clear,
systems work to a system
where obviously your things
are not working very well.
So there was a bit of a transition
and then realizing that it is you.
If you don't do, if you don't
make policy, you don't push,
it won't get done.
Of course there are other things
that were really surprising
like of course, I always
knew about Kenya being
at the forefront of digital
money, et cetera, et cetera
but coming back home and realizing that
to this day, I've never done
an over-the-counter transaction.
Everything for me is digital.
Yeah, okay, there is an occasional check
that I have to write, but beyond that.
So I think it was kind
of exciting in some ways,
but also quite challenging in others.
Of course, you don't
have much time to worry
about your own personal things.
It's all the issues in front of you,
but it's been quite challenging,
and I have enjoyed the challenge.
- Yeah, and you get to
see family all the time.
- Absolutely.
(Tavneet laughs)
And the weather is better
than Washington, I think,
than also New Haven.
And so that's something.
- Oh, way better.
Way better. (laughs)
Yes, one of the things I miss
most, the weather, sadly.
(laughs)
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, I think, it's
interesting, the digital stuff,
it's different seeing it from afar
and then like being sort of in-person
realizing just how
salient and broad it is,
and how much it's sort of pervasive
and a pervasive part of life
around, not just Nairobi,
but all over.
So let's talk about that piece a little.
Why do you think it's been so successful,
and what do you attribute that to?
Is it kind of the regulation side?
Do you think there's other
pieces of the success
of this that you would love to talk about?
- Okay, well, you're right, Tavneet.
Really Kenya is the cradle of FinTech.
We could also argue between
ourselves and Ethiopians
whether Kenya is the cradle of man,
but that can take us way into the evening.
- I think we'll both say the same thing.
It really is.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
Two Kenyans talking about this.
Yeah, we would agree instantly.
- Exactly. (laughs)
- So the cradle of FinTech,
and this is really where it started.
And really that was back in 2006,
that is when or among other things,
that's when we had the first iPhone.
But I think more importantly,
that's when the product
MPESA came into being,
actually in 2007,
that's when we actually
brought it into the live world
as it were.
And it has been very, very successful.
I think there are many ways of
measuring the success of this
but I think the first one
I need to point out is
how successful it has been
in bringing us forward
in terms of financial inclusion.
It was at 26% financial inclusion
or 26% of our adults
were included in 2007.
And now it is actually 83 plus percent.
So it has really helped us leapfrog
in terms of financial inclusion.
Those are things that I think you and I
in a policy environment
or class discussion,
you think also of doubling
financial inclusion to 50%.
I mean, that's huge.
So going to 85%, and still
increasing is something
that is obviously remarkable.
That's one way of measuring it.
But I think your question
is, well, the other ways,
but I'll come to that towards the end.
Why was it successful?
I think first and foremost
because there was a particular need.
So there was a need that it was feeling,
basically it came to us
through the transfer,
payments sort of as a payment platform.
So I could send money to people.
There was a need in the
sense that people needed
to send their money to
their family back home
in the rural areas.
And instead of giving it to the,
let's say to the bus conductor
or using the postal service
and et cetera, et cetera,
I mean this actually filled a very urgent
and indeed important need.
So, and that's really what happened.
So when it was devised,
it was a really devised
as a transfer between P2P
as we call it today, between persons.
So the need.
Secondly, the regulator looked at it,
and actually was innovative.
Meaning didn't want to
throttle the technology,
but actually looked at the
concerns like financial stability
and other concerns, security, et cetera
and allowed the innovator
to sort of improve
so as to mitigate against those risks,
and then allow them in a sort of a test
and learn environment
to launch the product.
Obviously knowing or understanding
that if there was a significant problem,
it would be pulled off the wall as it were
in the manner of speaking.
I think that was something
that was also very important
in terms of it.
So your question about regulation,
there were no regulations at the time.
So actually the regulations
came later in 2013.
That's when we put some
regulations in place,
but there was clear understanding
between the innovator
and ourselves about sort
of the rules of the game
and how we move that forward.
Obviously at the end of the day,
there was very effective collaboration
amongst everyone else, the
consumers, et cetera, regulators.
I mean, among everyone else
who came into this ecosystem.
And today, now it is a
very elaborate ecosystem
that is not just on the payment side,
but has grown into a well, a
mature sort of environment.
- Yeah, great, thanks.
So let's talk about
that mature environment.
You're just teeing up all
my questions, Governor.
I love it.
So one of the big pieces
that has grown from it
is kind of these apps or wallets
that allow you to borrow.
So the most successful example in Kenya
is a digital bank account that
the Commercial Bank of Africa
has built over the rails of mobile money.
It's called M-Shwari
just for the audience,
not for you, Governor of course.
And so that's one of the most successful
digital lending products
and digital bank accounts.
What do you see the future
of those sorts of things?
Are there benefits to them?
Are there risks?
Are you regulating them?
How do you think of
those sorts of products
over the rails of mobile money?
- Okay, precisely we
do have the rails now,
and now what we need to
do is to put on the wagons
as it were.
And I think one of them is
the one that you mentioned,
or one set of products
are the ones you mentioned
sort of lending.
And this is of micro lending.
That's what I guess we
used to call it before.
And now on your mobile,
you can call it all sorts
of other things, on your mobile device.
I think there's a great future for them.
And it isn't just that one wagon,
there are many other wagons
that need to be put in place.
As a matter of fact, with the rails now,
what we need to do is to work to make sure
that the environment continues to,
or the ecosystem continues to mature.
Of course there are some risks.
And I think these are the concerns
that we as a regulator
need to watch out for.
It's not our job to innovate
in the sense of saying
this is the direction,
let's say picking winners
in the old fashioned way.
We do understand that was actually a bane
of let's say industrial
policy in the past.
Industrial policy 1.2.
So not picking winners, but
actually setting the rules
so that the innovators can
expand as needed, et cetera.
But I think the concerns often
are, from our perspective,
financial stability,
and this could be if it is
in a lending environment
from over-borrowing or over-lending
or for that matter, the
issues of consumer protection,
so costs, et cetera.
And these are things that we need to
or the way the consumers
are being dealt with.
So that is something
that we as a regulator
need to be not just conscious of,
but to monitor and improve.
One of the concerns we have
actually is some so-called
well, we call them credit-only lenders
that are not regulated by the Central Bank
or for that matter by anyone else.
And unfortunately they've
grown like mushrooms,
and also like mushrooms,
you need to be careful
which mushrooms you eat.
Otherwise you may eat
some poisonous stuff.
And this actually have been a
big concern for the consumers.
As a matter of fact,
in terms of their size,
they are less than 1% of
a credit in the system.
Actually they are less
than the smallest bank
that we have here in Kenya.
But in terms of the
noise from the consumers,
I mean, it's huge.
So we are putting in
place now some regulations
and actually there is a bill
that is in parliament today
that will put order in this area.
But I think the point to
make is that it is important
to be clear from our perspective, CBK,
so the Central Bank's philosophy
with regard to regulation
which is you want to
maximize the opportunities
from innovation while
minimizing the risks.
And the benefits as you say, are huge.
One of the first papers I
read about the impact of MPESA
was yours, Tavneet.
You remember that?
Where you mentioned that
the impact of a MPESA
was what?
2% of GDP?
- 2% was reduction in poverty, yes.
- I never told you that, what
actually went through my mind
at the time.
You see, years ago, I was
trying to do a term paper
at Yale, of course.
And T.N. Srinivasan was
the one, it was his class.
And I don't remember what it was about,
but basically we were
discussing the impact of trade.
Yeah, the trade reforms
that were there at the time.
And T.N. was an expert on that.
And how actually in
general equilibrium models,
if you try to measure the
impact of a trade reform
liberalizing trade, the
models always give you
a very small estimate.
Somewhere like 1% to 2%.
But we all know that the
advantage of trade reforms
is much more than 2%.
And T.N. told me sort of in
passing as part of my paper.
I mean, he made the point that
actually the benefits come
from new products.
And I remember going away
trying to figure out,
okay, how am I gonna
model these new products?
Creation destruction
or whatever else it is.
But anyway, the point I'm making
is your 2% as you mentioned
is actually a major under estimate
because you have all these other things
that have mushroomed being in the wagons.
And those have actually huge benefit
as we have actually seen.
- Yeah, absolutely, Governor.
I completely agree.
That's like the pure rails on the rails
with nothing on the rails, except that.
Yeah, I will say, you mentioned T.N.,
I took T.N.'s class only a
few years after you, Governor,
but I did.
It was like a trade development class.
- He was still the same person. (chuckles)
- Yeah, I remember him fondly.
So I can imagine him saying
just what you're saying.
Yeah, I think trying to aggregate
up all the bits and pieces
will take us some while as researchers,
but I think it also means
there's a lot of interesting
open questions to understand
what each of these products
does and how you can design them better,
how you can build them better.
I personally have been
a little underwhelmed
by the innovation
'cause I feel like there
should be more products.
So I'm hoping there's a lot more coming.
And I like your view of regulation being
we don't wanna restrict innovation,
we just wanna manage the
risk the financial system
that come from it.
- But Tavneet if you
just let me say one thing
that just struck me now, (indistinct).
You see I spend a lot of
time listening to innovators.
I mean, they come here and
do the dog and pony show
and they show us what they are doing,
their widgets and things like that.
And there are certain
things that strike me.
First, it's a lot of
them that are in Africa
are still stuck in the payments area.
Payments, payments, payments.
Now they all say that they want to reduce
the cost of payments,
but I think they need to expand
and begin to look at
other problems elsewhere
in the financial space as it were.
And I think that is what
I would strongly encourage
the innovators if there
innovators on this webinar.
In the US actually it's not
so much in the payments space.
It's more in the capital markets area,
wealth management, et cetera.
That's where there's a lot
more action by FinTech,
et cetera, et cetera.
But I think my point here
is let the innovators
look at the problems and figure
out how to fix the problem.
Let them not come with
a sort of a prefixed
or preordained idea that
everything is payments
because that's not true.
I think we need more wagons elsewhere.
- Yeah, I'm in complete agreement.
Sadly, I'm not gonna
disagree with you, Governor.
No controversy here.
- We'll get to a point
where we are gonna disagree,
I'm sure.
- Yeah, I'm sure,
but I agree.
- It's the first time
we agree on everything.
- I just gave a spiel on a
call this morning, Governor
where I sort of gave this
example, there's not enough wagons
and wagons that work for 70% of people,
not 5% of people in the country.
I think a lot of people get absorbed
in the Nairobi lifestyle,
kind of that's their view of the country.
And to be honest until I
did field work in Kenya,
I didn't really appreciate
kind of the breadth
that is our country.
So I think that's a piece
where people's use cases
often are for a small group of people.
And then the wagon
doesn't really take off.
It just doesn't do all that much.
So I would also encourage
people to think about
not just wagons, but wagons
that work for large portions
of our population, not just a few.
Awesome.
So we've talked a bit about this stuff.
What do you see as the future of FinTech?
So when we think about innovation,
where do you see the
scope for those products?
What do you think that FinTech itself
can really bring to the continent?
Bring to our company?
- Okay, my view is that the
future of FinTech in Africa
is bright.
I mean, let's begin
there for many reasons.
First, there are many needs.
You can look around,
and you'll see many problems
that need to be resolved
in the financial space we
are talking, of course.
And I would call this
sort of more generally
the democratization of financial services.
You and I can have a lot
of less financial services
that are available to us.
You can go to even wealth
managers or whatever
or savings options, not
everybody in Africa has that.
As a matter of fact, there's a lot of,
if we want to move ahead
in terms of investments,
savings is a key driver,
but we need to get the
savings from everyone else.
So I think there is a lot of need here.
Secondly, you don't
have legacy structures.
So you can actually
leapfrog from where we are
with very little in terms of structures
to something that is let's say
designed with 21st technology
et cetera, et cetera.
Sadly, remember 60% of our
population in Sub-Saharan Africa,
are youth.
And that is about 1/3 of our workforce
is below the age of 25.
So you have a lot of let's say,
the pyramid is a truly a pyramid.
And a lot of the youth are
educated, et cetera, et cetera.
I mean, it's not being
a PhD sort of person
that you need to, that's
not education here.
As a matter of fact as we have discovered
the Kenyan population are
very technologically savvy.
I have stories about this,
and I'm sure we can tell
stories if we more time
about meeting people
who are actually doing,
let's say things that you
and I are kind of not quite
get there quickly, right?
They have it in their fingertips
in terms of using technology,
adopting technology.
Our grandmother's kind of very
accustomed to technologies
that maybe people in the US are not.
I mean, we're still having
trouble with our TV remote,
et cetera.
Well, actually people
here are very advanced
in terms of dealing with those things.
But also, as I say, I think
people should begin to look at,
I mean, some of the
things just as examples,
I know a lot of us are
stuck with the technology.
So the questions I get
are blockchain, DLT,
things like that.
I think that's looking
at things the wrong way.
Look at the problem.
What problem are we trying to resolve?
And then ask the question,
what solution do you need?
So it's a bit like writing a term paper.
You don't write the term paper
by first solving the equations
or whatever else it is.
What is the problem that
you are dealing with?
What is the economic problem
or the research problem
that you're dealing with?
So it is more that.
Having said that, I really
think that applying the,
let's say all the ideas
that are out there,
Africa would really leapfrog,
not just on FinTech,
but in other areas as well.
And I think here is
where much more excited
because I mean there's so
much that can change quickly.
I talked about more than tripling
of the financial
inclusion numbers in Kenya
and actually elsewhere in Africa
because of such a sort of
transformative technology.
I mean, you have other things
as well that have changed
in that way.
I mean, in terms of, for instance
and the example that I remember is Rwanda.
Rwanda in terms of ease of doing business
in that much maligned, let's
say, let's just leave it.
- You shouldn't talk about
ease of doing business anymore.
- I should. (laughs)
I mean, that's going to embarrass us
as the economist as well.
But I think the point is in 2007
there were at number 130
something, 135 or thereabouts.
And by 2017, there were
at number four or five
in terms of doing
business and other things.
I mean, an example that I also in my head
is in 2007, Nigeria was
the second largest importer
of cement in the world.
Number one, of course is the US.
But then in 10 years later,
a little more than 10 years later,
actually they were sufficient,
self-sufficient in cement and
actually pushing to export
because there has been such
a change in that industry.
So I'm just making the point
that most of the things
if they are done correctly
can be transformative.
Of course, as development experts
or people interested in
development as economists
we ask ourselves, is it actually changing
the lives of people?
And I think it is, I think it is.
- Yeah, excellent.
Yeah, I think what problem
you're trying to solve
is a big one.
Especially when people talk
about blockchain as you said.
I always pushed, like, what is it solving
that a regular pretty decent
database won't solve for me?
Tell me there's value.
But I think people often
don't quite get that view
of the world,
which is try and figure out the problem
you're trying to solve for at least,
in my books, also not just
one person, many people.
I want it to be a reasonably broad problem
you're trying to solve.
Yeah, I think FinTech will
be interesting to watch
over the next couple of decades.
I think it will either
take off and be great
or kind of we won't have
figured out enough innovation
to get as much out of it as we could.
And I hope it's the former.
Let me go back a little bit,
and just talk a bit more
about kind of policymaking
in Africa or Kenya more specifically.
We've known each other for
a few years now, Governor.
I think we met right as you got appointed,
if I remember correctly. (laughs)
And I think it was the museum.
I think that's where we met
with the national museum.
- Absolutely.
- Yeah, so, I know you've
worked extremely hard in Kenya
to make our banking system,
should I say more efficient,
let's say more efficient
(laughs) without being explicit.
I'd love to hear your perspective
on what you think your biggest
success has been so far.
And also what you found hard
about your current position.
- Wow, and all within
two minutes. (laughs)
- No, no, take your time.
We have time, we have time.
We have plenty of time.
- Okay, well, you see, Tavneet,
I am not sure at this
point, one can look back
and sort of be comfortable,
but then let that be.
But if I were to, okay, fine.
If I'm thinking of the
most significant things,
I think the first one in
my mind without a doubt
would be COVID-19, the
response to COVID-19.
This has been a very difficult year
for any policy maker anywhere
and for any economist anywhere.
And the numbers have
been swinging numbers,
not so much numbers,
but economies have been
swinging huge numbers.
I remember in March last year
I was looking at some of my
notes actually from a year ago
because of we are now at one year there.
And I was looking at some of
the statements that were made
by the Jay Powell, the
Governor at the Fed, US Fed.
And he was saying that we
would have something like
well, actually 30% sort of declines,
things that nobody ever thought of.
You're thinking huge declines is 5%,
but it was amazing off
the charts surviving that.
But it isn't just surviving,
is actually figuring out
policies that would maintain
and strengthen the economy.
Even as the containment
measures were put in place,
restrictions on travel, close
down, et cetera, et cetera,
I think we have been quite
successful all things considered.
And we have had some sort of retrospection
over the last few weeks.
And in terms of, for instance,
the way the banks have responded
or responded at the beginning,
we've been quite,
I think we did reasonably well on that.
The decline actually,
we still haven't seen the first numbers,
I mean the first print numbers,
but they estimate
something like 1% growth,
maybe a little less, but around there.
Actually, I'm not sure it is just that,
but let's wait a few weeks
and they'll give us the first numbers.
But I think I told you this, Tavneet.
The first time, I mean,
from around February
which is when we began
to see this thing coming.
The first time I actually
slept a sound sleep
throughout the night
was sometime in October.
All those many months sort of figuring,
in a sense, being very very
uncomfortable with things,
et cetera, my mind not at ease.
So I think that is number one
in terms of what I'm proud of,
and what may be has
been the most important
if we had not done what we did,
I think we'll be talking a
completely different story.
That's one.
The second one is maybe
what you mentioned,
but the way I put it is
sort of the strengthening
of the banking sector.
And I think there has been a lot there.
First and foremost,
I would say is the
culture that was pervasive
in the banking sector.
A culture that is probably not consistent
with proper pricing and
ethical practices, et cetera.
So clean up of the sector,
of course that also meant that we had
to take the hard decision
of closing some banks.
We've closed three and
put them in receivership.
But one, we actually
put them in liquidation
and the other two in receivership.
So it was tough obviously
knowing the impact on the people,
and until COVID 19 came along,
this was the toughest
decisions that I ever did
or we ever did.
And we didn't take
those decisions lightly.
I remember one in particular,
we were up 48 hours
straight working on this.
And that was sort of the final moments
after many weeks and a few months also
sort of trying to deal with those issues.
So that is one.
Now of course, it isn't
enough just to clean up.
You need to put it in play.
You need to sort of begin
a new normal as it were.
And I think that is what
we've tried to impact
all the actors in the sector.
And we want the banking sector
to work with, and for Kenyans
and actually during this COVID-19 period,
it is because of that sort
of new found way of looking
at things that we have been
able to do what we we did.
So in that sense, just a
thumbnail sketch on this.
It was more important for Banks.
Banks understood that it is more important
to protect their balance sheet
as opposed to protecting
their PNL, so their profits.
And in a sense, that's
why they restructured
some of the loans with their
borrowers so as to maintain.
The borrowers of course were selected
in the sense that they were already.
I mean, they had performing loans.
So you are not restructuring.
You're not evergreening.
You are doing the right thing
which is only performing loans,
restructuring them to
support them, et cetera.
So that is important.
And of course, customer centricity,
correct pricing et cetera, et cetera.
So that's number two.
Number three briefly is strengthening the,
this is something that
most people have not seen
because it's really fixing the backroom,
things in the backend.
And this sort of strengthening
the financial infrastructure.
So the infrastructure itself,
for instance, hardening it to be,
I mean on cyber issues,
hardening it a lot more.
Improving for instance the
credit information system
which we have done significant
refresh in that space,
but also other things.
We've improved our RTGS
which is our real time
gross settlement systems.
And frankly, this now
is at world standard.
And we can now move to as a 24/7 economy
because we have the capacity to do that.
I mean, to run that in terms of numbers,
in terms of all the options that you have.
But importantly, data.
I mean, if we are in the 21st
century, we have to talk data.
And so we are doing a lot of work
to make sure that we are
putting data together
in a particular way
so that we can make data-based decisions
rather than sort of random
decisions in a sense.
So there's also having
a better central security
depository system.
With all these things,
we will really be in the 21st century.
And at that point, it
wouldn't be just saying,
we are an important financial system.
It will be well, we are there.
It is Nairobi because
everything else is in place.
And those are the three
things I could probably say.
- Great, thanks, Governor.
I appreciate it.
I'm gonna switch to Q&A in a second.
But yeah, I think,
it feels like with all of
these improvements now,
the innovators just
have no excuse anymore.
Come play.
I think that's what we
need to say to innovators
is just come play.
And Nairobi is the
greatest city in the world.
No exceptions.
- I think that we are
not gonna argue, Tavneet.
(both laugh)
We agree entirely.
- Yes.
I argue with lots of people
over Nairobi being the best city though.
I will say.
All right, I'm gonna start some
questions if you don't mind
from the audience, Governor.
I hope that's okay.
I'll start with a question
from Irene Wangaki.
Irene, thanks for being here.
She asks FinTech credit at the moment
is mostly for consumption smoothing.
Most SMEs have to go to
banks for sizable funding.
M-Shwari is not lending to SMEs,
and there's still a lot of
consumer protection issues there.
Do you have a vision for how FinTechs
can solve SME financing issues?
- Well, excellent,
excellent, excellent, Irene.
I think this is something
we've been working on
for some time.
I think we need to dial
back maybe two years.
It was January of 2019
when we went out there
and began looking at the FinTechs.
Not FinTechs, I'm sorry, SMEs.
And I toured the various
places, the various markets.
Actually I loved that.
Since my return, I hadn't had
that sort of freedom to walk
in the thick of things.
Anyway, but one of the
things that came out of that
actually is a product
that is called Stawi.
And basically this is an
anytime anywhere financing
for SMEs.
And it really, the whole
point here is that as an SME,
my information in terms
of transactions, et cetera
that I do, buying selling is on my phone,
say my mobile platform.
So if that information is
gathered and assessed correctly,
you can actually provide
a pretty good sense
of a credit score there.
As a matter of fact, I don't
remember the numbers now,
but it is better than
having a credit officer
in terms of judging the
credit worthiness of somebody
using that information.
So this is something that I think we,
well, unfortunately COVID-19 came.
And so that was put on
let's say on the shell,
on skis, on ice or whatever else it is.
But I think now that the
economy is beginning to come
or is coming back, this
will be a central point.
Now I should hasten them
to say that the SMEs,
they need credit, but
they need credit plus,
and that plus element, other elements,
like maybe being given some sort of,
well being trained to
do the accounts better,
or for that matter,
improving their skills.
I mean, one of the ones
that we were thinking of,
and I saw this is (indistinct) welders.
And they need to be taught
how to do better welding
sort of joints and things like that.
And basically they can
do that in three hours.
So the bank works with them,
and they bring some sort of truck on site
that actually they taught
how to weld for three hours
in the day there.
And I think it is those sorts of things,
innovative ways of let's say
upscaling people's skills,
providing them with credit.
One of the person I remember
when I went on this,
whatever it is, excursion,
was a painter and a carpenter.
So he would sell paint to
the people that are painting.
They repair your car, and
then they have to repaint it.
So his job was to sell.
It was all about paint.
And we asked him, so what will it take
for you to move to the next level?
And he said, well, actually all
it will take me is something
like a $1,000 worth of equipment
which would make him sort of,
or allow him to sort of mix the paints,
and therefore have all sorts of colors.
Not just have the, I don't
know, the 10 different colors
or however many colors you need
in that sort of environment.
So I'm just making the point
that the SME story is a big one
and we need to work on
it in all directions.
We just started recently
a credit guarantee scheme,
but credit is not everything,
it is credit plus.
- Great, thanks, Governor.
I've got a question from Ali
O. Paul who starts off saying
Kenya's work on FinTech
is truly impressive.
Thanks, Ali.
The Governor will take full
credit for it, don't worry.
He asks being the cradle of FinTech,
he's curious about what
lessons you might have
for Central Bank policy
of having a mature FinTech environment.
You touch on the
financial stability angle.
Are there any specific
lessons for the transmission
of monetary policy that you think about?
- Wow, difficult question.
(laughs)
I mean, generally, I think,
depending on the wagons
that you put there, you'll have different,
let's say risks on transmission
on monetary policy.
Obviously, if it is lending,
then this has a significant impact.
And we've had to do some work.
As a matter of fact, for
you to know we are improving
our monetary policy framework.
Precisely because of reasons such as this
because now mobile
money is very important.
It is no longer just something
that is in the corner
somewhere lending, et cetera.
And therefore you need to incorporate that
when you are thinking
or designing a policy.
So there is that.
But I think that is only one angle.
The other elements, depending
on the wagons, as I say,
if you are into savings,
by the way, remind me, Tavneet,
to tell them about our savings product.
- Yes.
- If you're into savings product,
then obviously transmission
will be somewhat different,
but it will still be there.
My point is, you need to
think through it step by step.
And so there's no shortcut.
You have to do the sort of the brute force
sort of step by step checking
of how this monetary policy
is being transmitted
through all the channels
and indeed through all the
products that are there.
But in terms of Central
Bank policy more generally,
I don't think the biggest issue for me
for this product is on the risk.
I don't think it is on monetary policy.
I think the biggest risk is
more on financial stability.
And that is an important element.
And I think here is where
you need to be more on top
in terms of monitoring.
Monitoring, getting data
is so very important.
This is one of the reasons
why we are much further ahead
on data and we want to make sure
that we have sort of a data lake
that you can slice and
dice any whichever way.
And I think in that sense,
then you can see the problem
before it comes over
the horizon as it were.
You can already begin
to the elements of that.
So that is there.
And then the other thing,
the last point on this is
the law needs to change.
I mean, a lot of us
think that you have a law
and it is static.
Actually, in this area
because it's very dynamic,
the law needs to be much more malleable.
And so how you craft it,
the way you write a law,
well, that that's one issue.
But I think also appreciating
that you do need to go to the
law and amend it and tweak it
in whichever way,
and maybe it is in the law
directly, it's also other things
like the Prudential
guidelines when they come out
you need to, I mean, writing this quickly
and change them as needed.
So those are the directions
I would probably put out for,
I mean, to think in terms
of Central Bank policy.
- Yeah, to lead to one of
the questions in the chat.
I'm not gonna ask the question directly,
but it's about kind of, how
do you think about big data
that's also coming from the telcos,
and is there a piece of that
that gets regulated by you guys
for use in credit scoring,
et cetera, like you said,
and how do you think of that data piece?
I know we have a data bill
that imposes significant
restrictions on the use of data,
but we're going into a world
where you know a lot about
people from their phones,
and as people use smartphones,
you learn even more.
The digital lending apps can see Facebook,
can see your car records, can
see your text message content.
So we're getting to the point
where some people have
access to a lot of datas.
Do you think of how you regulate them
or is that up to the
communications commission,
and how do you see that
regulation process?
Because it fits into the
credit banking system somewhat.
- Yeah, a good question.
I think we are definitely involved in it.
Let's start there.
But I think it isn't so
much who is involved in it
that is important.
I think it is the attitude with which
or the prism that you view
the data that is available
wherever it is.
I think first and foremost,
the data belongs to the consumer.
It does not belong to the telco.
It does not belong to
the, let's say the bank
that is working with the individual telco
or whatever else it is.
And therefore to use the data,
you do need to provide them with,
I mean, you need to do it
with a complete understanding
of the consumer.
And here is where I think,
and sorry to put it this way,
but I think we all understand it.
Your iPhone or whatever, it updates
to a new operating system, right?
13 points, whatever.
I don't know now it's
13 or whatever it is.
- I don't actually know either. (laughs)
- Whatever it is.
This is exactly my point.
So for me, at least it updates.
I leave it in the evening,
that's when it'll update.
And then in the morning, it'll ask me,
push this to agree on the
conditions, and yes or no.
I mean, you know so well,
and they know that I cannot say no.
I just push yes, and move on.
It's not informed.
So this informed consent
is very important.
It has to be brought down to
the level of the consumer.
And also the consumer needs
to be given many opportunities
to in a sense withdraw from
all the sort of engagement
and all the data is
removed and it's hard work.
Surely, it's hard work.
But it is important to do all there is
to protect the consumer.
I think what has happened now,
and this is the problem of
some of the digital lenders
that we are dealing with
is when you join, they will ask you,
we would like to use
your list of contacts.
And then you say, yes,
and you move on, right?
- Yeah.
- And then what happens?
They haven't told you how
they are gonna use it.
But what happens is when you don't repay,
they will call people
on your contacts list.
I mean, just think of that.
Your family, your boss,
and your priest back in the rural area.
And everybody's been told,
listen, so-and-so hasn't
and this is your brother.
He hasn't paid up.
You need to do something.
So I'm just making the point that
that is not informed consent.
- I use that example a lot saying,
also, I think, Governor, the difference is
if Apple had something really bad
in the terms and conditions,
someone would have found it
and there would have been a process
around uproar to solve it.
That's less so in this case, I think.
The institutions don't
function quite the same way.
- But Tavneet, here, I disagree with you.
I don't think that-
- Yay, something you disagree with me on.
(Patrick laughs)
- I mean, there was this,
anyway, it's on my phone somewhere,
would have read it to you,
but when they introduced
something, when was it?
Back in 2019.
And in a sense it was, anyway,
it wasn't informed consent.
Let's just be honest.
- Yeah, I think this
is gonna be a big issue
is how we think about who owns data,
and how you give consent to
use that data and for what,
and as we do digital
identification as well
with the Huduma number
and things like that
and start to connect it to things,
I think this is gonna
become really important
from like you said a consumer
information perspective,
but also a regulatory perspective.
- And I think that's the,
to be honest this is where I have.
Well, we've been a bit concerned
about the large telcos.
If I may just have a segue into that,
because in a sense there is a
bit of a monopolistic behavior
as they try and sort of grab data.
There's a lot of data
in the payment space,
a lot of data in the
payments space about people,
et cetera, et cetera.
And so when you get a large telco
getting into the payments space,
and not just a large telco,
I'm just talking about
the big tech generally,
we need to be careful.
I mean, and this is one of
the things that in my mind
when you think of some
of the large big techs
around the world sort of
making inroads into Africa,
I think the first question is
what are they gonna do with the data?
And I think in some sense they also know
that there's a first mover advantage.
So once they grab some of this data,
it would be very difficult
to get it out of their hands.
And so I think we need
to be careful about data.
We have a responsibility as regulators
to make sure that the people
that we are responsible for
do not fall in those sort of
problems in our jurisdictions.
- Great.
I think we're close to
running out of time.
So I think we should wrap up.
There is just two minutes left, Governor.
So let me take the
opportunity to thank everybody
who's attended and thank
you for being here.
Sorry, we didn't get to all the Q&A,
but I really wanna thank you, Governor,
for being with us today and
kicking off our celebrations
of the Growth Center and the
IDE program, and making time.
I know it's evening in Nairobi
and just having a conversation
with us which is way more fun
than speaking, I think.
And so for, at least for me, it is.
I hope it was for you too,
but we're really grateful for your time,
and for you being here today.
I don't know, Tony, if
you wanna add anything.
- Thank you, Tavneet.
- That was great.
Really interesting.
The Q&A format was quite useful.
And I learned a bunch
of things I didn't know
about how money and
finances work in Kenya.
I knew a few things, but
it's quite interesting,
and you're kind of on the forefront there.
I think we can learn a lot from that
from what's going on there.
So I think it was a great event,
very much enjoyed you both participating.
And I'll just close with saying,
this just shows the extent to
which I think Yale is a center
for development economics.
So this kind of
conversation happening here
is an illustration of that.
And let me congratulate
again the IDE program
on 65 years of existence.
It's one of the premier programs
of its kind in the world.
So that was great in
showcasing all that success
with that program.
So thank you for participating.
- Thank you, Tony.
Thank you, Tavneet.
- Hopefully see you in Nairobi soon.
- We hope so.
Looking forward to seeing you.
- Yes, sir.
Thank you for being here,
we really appreciate it.
- Okay, all the best.
Goodbye to the participants.
- [Tavneet] Thank you.
- [Tony] Thank you.